Spanish police arrest eight suspected Islamic militants...
...who were accused of planning attacks in Spain...
...and recruiting fighters to send to Syria and Iraq.
In Bangladesh, rescuers continue to search through the rubble of a cement factory...
...after it collapsed Thursday, with at least seven people dead and 40 hospitalized.
In Australia, Vanuatu authorities prepare for possible evacuations...
...as category five Cyclone Pam intensifies.
The Turrialba volcano spews ash and gas over central Costa Rica,...
...prompting evacuations from the strongest eruption since 1996.
And finally from Thailand, elephants were treated to fruit buffets and a day off...
...as their handlers celebrate National Elephant Day.